savez vous comment écrire un message
secret aux 20e siècle c'était le grand
jeu des espions je vais vous montrer
pour écrire un message secret il vous
faut à citrons inverse un pinceau et une
feuille vous écrivez votre message
secret avec le jus de citron
et voilà mon message secret bien se crée
un maintenant vous laissez sécher pour
le lire il faut une bougie et la
présence d'un adulte car on ne joue pas
avec le feu au contact de la chaleur les
sucres contenus dans le jus de citron
caramélise et colore le papier ce qui
permet de lire le message
et voilà chers epicure yeux ça vous a
donné envie d'essayer montrez moi vos
messages